hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm currently at my hotel in packs
and I gotta say I just finished setting
up everything I'm playing on my laptop
here and this is probably the creepiest
environment I've ever played in because
it's super dark in here I didn't bring
enough adequate lighting there's like
empty rooms like left and right that are
just kind of sitting there and also
there's a [ __ ] mirror right in front
of me like right there
so it's freaking me the hell out to look
up and see someone staring back at me
while it's super and also I don't want
to start screaming like a madman because
I think my neighbors might think I'm
insane which they probably are a do
because I'm a B so I'm gonna play the
game that has scared me more than any
other because of course I'm gonna put
myself in a situation where I'm in
horrifically horrible hotel room okay
whatever I've done let's just go play it
and cranking the volume up way high okay
so I am going to try to be quiet here at
the same time but you know I kind of
remember okay I remember all of the
horrors that this has brought upon mine
he's right here he's so creepy looking
look he's so ugly his face is all wrong
and where the hell am I going I didn't
even know where I'm going I mean I'm not
now whatever I have no idea what I'm
talking about
so anyway I'm gonna I'm legitimately
gonna try to beat this game but I'm
trying I'm gonna try not to make myself
you know I'm trying to make myself be
quiet and not scream but I don't know
how well that's gonna work
and I'm hearing like random noises like
suddenly the it okay okay okay none of
that alright tell anyway out there
random noises that kick on this game has
a bad habit of every time I say
something it does the thing that it says
it's gonna do also I think it turn the
brightness down cuz I can't see anything
ah nice sauna to cleanse my pores also
I've never recorded
it's too early for them to be here right
if I turn around he's not gonna be there
okay okay that's just a steam okay I am
NOT thoroughly freaked out good job good
job game good job you've done it again
kudos to you and kudos to this creepy
ass hotel room like seriously all I've
got is this little desk lamp here Hank
I'm not sure what's going on all the
static on the radio Phil okay that's
fantastic Phil but I'm in a little bit
of a situation here I've got some
problems with the Mole Man
also the audio quality might not be as
stellar as it was before I've literally
I was bare-bones so I had to bring my
old blue Yeti I mean the quality I did
tons of videos on the blue Yeti but I
mean I hear a thing I don't want to play
this game I don't want to play
I hear I've you got the volume way
turned up more than usual or I'm
actually being quiet enough to hear
everything that's going on in this game
okay there's a siren outside I'm also in
the heart of Cincinnati ever since it
I'm a Seattle right now pack starts
tomorrow if you want to see all the
stuff that I've got going on in packs be
sure to follow me on twitter i'm doing
vines and posting regularly here
whatever everybody that quit dropping
keys all right I've read all the notes
I'm pretty sure what why you're doing
that thing that you did before with the
breezy thingy and I don't like it okay
my vision has gone wibbly-wobbly again
but that usual that doesn't guarantee
that there's a monster nearby that only
means that something has started
where did he come from stop staring at
me just stop staring at me out I'm sorry
neighbors
I'm sorry clipping the microphone trying
okay okay
it always does this this game does this
I say something like that doesn't mean
there's a monster nearby hello friend
laughs you heard the word Jesus and then
mole Jesus and then they tried it I'm
also like you know the problem of this
old microphone is it has a problem with
I don't have a windscreen here either so
you're kind of getting the full breath
every time I I you know it right into
the microphone depicts it right up I
apologize but the best I can do Stu keep
giving you content I've got there some
amazing Polaris videos by the way on the
way next week we recorded so much and
it's so epic I can't even tell you about
it but it is probably the most amazing
thing sorry game Oh pity you it is so
damn dark I turn the brightness now way
too much total weirdo screaming to
myself total stranger weirdo I'm not
even gonna see a monster before it's too
late it's just gonna come up to me and
just totally just in my face like it did
before damn it letter forgot the keys to
access gate I'm on my last glow stick
there's no way I'll be able to find them
without the extra light yeah no joke
it's kind of dark in here you know it's
kind of dark in here too it you stop
staring at me I see you around the
corner of my eye what's that what was
that what is that what does this mean
I've never seen this symbol before does
that mean I'm close to something
important
I do I really don't know I don't know
here okay okay mr. mole man come on out
and play I've got a present for you damn
it Hank
okay I'm done I've read all the notes
before so that I'm not gonna I'm gonna
assume that there's nothing new to be
heard from them
so okay all right that's cool too
how about you don't do that that'd be
nice all right just carrying on as I go
around the thing I do okay is that the
real one or is that the lying one
because I've learned that one of them is
from the mall man and one is from actual
person person that's probably from the
person person now I'm going right into
the molded mi-mi-mi-mi-mi okay all right
no more man yet okay okay okay okay
[Applause]
is he behind me still is he behind me
yeah so damn hard to be I see this
wide-eyed [ __ ] over here look right at
me it's the freakiest thing dude I'm
gonna play with a mirrored friend me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay I can't play this game without
screaming so I got going to so I'm gonna
be recording more videos from this um
I'm gonna be playing more I'm going to
be recording more videos very soon I may
or may not get my hands on an oculus
rifts for while I'm here so look forward
to more videos and remember there's lots
of stuff going on on Facebook and
Twitter as I'm exploring PAX Prime so
and if you're there feel free to come up
and say hi to me I'm always happy to
meet a fan just make sure you tell me
that you know you know who I am
I have this one guy that came up to me
and it was just like hey how's it going
and I'm like hey how's it going and he
just started talking to me as if it was
a conversation that I had no idea that
he was fast I just are talkative but it
was like weird oh you know who I am okay
so anyway just uh I don't know what I'm
rambling about
I'm gonna go home now thank you goodbye
everybody
bye